will they draw plate Vsauce this is your
home for some of the coolest creations
from everyday people this is beauty
building Brian Duxbury built an
interactive mario lamp the 8-bit light
is a custom touch sensitive question
block lamp made of laser-cut plexiglass
to turn it on and off just punch the
bottom of the cube and gain a one-up
after four months of work the Lego
Mindstorms NXT beer machine is complete
it's controlled using a bluetooth and
features a conveyor system bottle opener
and a cooling system obviously it's
faster just to get a beer out of the
fridge yourself but the design and
imagination behind this creation is
incredible Tommy Craig's meanwhile is
transforming tree trunks of fallen trees
into elaborate sculptures he actually
carved trees anonymously and had locals
baffled but they ended up really liking
the sculptures including this massive
Kingfisher and Matt collie creates his
own awesome figures he began breaking
toys as a distraction from his
illustration work and has made a ton of
these over the past 15 years including
an entire x-men lineup Doctor Who and
the Justice League gallery 1988 is this
thing on exhibit is dedicated to Weird
Al the second annual art exhibit
features tributes to the legendary
musical comedian including such classics
as like a surgeon eat it and Amish
paradise Darin ray created a piece
called the history of gaming and this
speed art video chronicles that painting
finally blow to watch the whole thing
and now the wwa galleries epic tribute
to Saturday morning cartoons
[Music]
finally NC winters abandoned menagerie
features a host of pop-culture inspired
paintings and his works include Zelda
the Blue Bomber and my personal favorite
sloth plan to solve state musical Tesla
coils recreate Leonard Skynyrd's Sweet
Home Alabama
[Music]
James little V Mills plays all the
instruments in this mass effect 3 cover
captain credible created the SNES doom
box finally here's the dungeon song from
The Legend of Zelda performed on beer
bottles
[Music]
somebody your own PDP's as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo give a special
shout out to Rick and ami he created the
awesome Vsauce animation you saw at the
very beginning of this video so click
here to check out his personal channel
make sure you subscribe and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]